Hey, I'm Donald Bell for CNET.com.
We're here at Apple's iPad 2 Launch Event and I'm holding the iPad 2.
In fact, I'm holding the white version of the iPad 2.
There are now two colors: a white version and a black version.
All the same prices, all the same capacities as last year's,...
...but you're now getting a much thinner design, a lighter design,...
...and also getting a faster processor.
There's a dual-core A5 processor in here.
It's promising nine times the graphics performance of the original iPad.
You're also getting a few new features.
You're getting a FaceTime feature for video calling.
You get a HD camera on the back and a VGA camera on the front.
Apple is also announcing two new applications for the iPad, their own applications.
One is iMovie for the iPad, which was available before in the iPhone and the iPod Touch.
It's now coming to the iPad.
Well, at least, the most sophisticated mobile version of iMovie we've seen yet.
The other application that Apple announced today for the iPad is GarageBand.
This is gonna be a pretty cool application out there for you musical types.
It does multitrack recording, virtual instruments, a lot of fun.
We're gonna see this thing March 11th.
So, having played around with the iPad 2, the little bit that I've had it here,...
...I have to say the thing I like about it the most is how thin and light Apple's been able to get the design.
Having seen a lot of their competitors this past year,...
...I haven't seen anything that's gotten this small.
And I think being able to preserve that 10 - hour battery life is a big deal.
It's gonna be harder to be able to keep up with that.
So, for CNET.com, I'm Donald Bell showing off the Apple iPad 2.